hey what's up everybody welcome to
the dr john dolone show i'm john
i'm glad you're here hey listen this is
the second this is ama number two
we got james kelly all of us are in on
this one we
recently put out on the the interwebs
hey if you got any questions for the
the second round if you ask me anything
i got a
shirt with lots of shiny buttons on it
it's actually a t-shirt with buttons i
don't even think it'd work
and james has his jean jacket i think
james you sleep in that jean jacket
uh maybe maybe i do i like how you keep
your
private life private and we got kelly
back there looking beautiful as always
and then zach hiding out away from the
camera so
they sent everybody sent in a bunch of
fun questions we actually gonna break
this up into two different shows right
so we got
the ask me anything's
pretty much like how i live what i read
and do and stuff like that and then we
had another one what were the other ones
so we have some that are like people
asking questions about you
then we have some that are just like
general questions like how do i deal
with this
so we're gonna do another show where
it's like rapid fire answering those
questions
at some point rapid fire is gonna be so
great for me because i talk so much
yeah it just being like how about you
say that in one sentence i think my
brain will just pop off had popped off
had popped off all right so let's get
right into it
kelly how are you i'm doing great thank
you how are you oh my gosh
your on the phone voice is so different
than your human voice
are you the mom who's like you could
shut up hello
yep totally oh
all right so here we go we are going
through these
ask me any things uh and you guys feel
free to pitch in at any moment okay so
first question do what we will i know
you will you guys do anyway
y'all don't know this when you are
listening to the show or watching it
they can talk to me in my earphones and
i can't make a face i can
never mind all right so current reads
what am i currently reading
now so here's my current reads i brought
him with me this time
so um a guy named blake bailey one of my
former students
mailed me this book the other day he was
one of my former uh
he's students there at texas tech and
it's
a memoir by frederick beekner when he
talks about some
pretty significant trauma he had in his
life i'm rereading this book
adult children of emotionally immature
parents it's such a rock star book by dr
lindsey gibson
and this book is
phenomenal it's called the biology of
desire why addiction is
not a disease it is
wonderful there's a whole a whole bunch
of new literature new scholarship coming
out
about this idea that um addiction is not
a disease we got so excited to call it a
disease
for two reasons one we saw brain change
when people like did cocaine we saw
their brain change we got all excited
hey that's a disease and number two
we are so adamant about putting
um addiction drugs pornography working
too much
as a character issue right if you do
this it's because you're bad if you do
this it's because you're lazy or stupid
that once we were able to call it a
disease then people could finally get
the help they needed
and what this book is coming back and
saying is man
your brain changes all day every day you
get a phone call
you laugh real hard you watch something
that's funny then you watch it again and
you send that clip to your friend and
you watch it again your brain's changing
all the time
and so it brain change is not unique to
using drugs or working too much et
cetera
and man
can we all just stop with the blaming
people
and lying to people so it's not a
disease
but it does have some addictive
qualities it is not a
permanent brain change yet your brain
does change
part all that goes into itself so dr
mark lewis here
um the biology of desire it's a really
great read
and then this man i talked about this i
think in the last ama guys
this is discipline equals free freedom
by jocko
this is the simplest book i've read in a
while and it's really rich
and so i'm doing a daily thing with it
where i read through it again i've read
through it several times and i'm
continuing to read through it
and it hasn't i haven't come across a
day yet where
man jocko doesn't say something that
really gets into me and
it may be one of the top three or four
mental health books i've read in 2021
it's really good um and it's simple
right and then
on the fiction front i brought some of
these books man
this book octavia butler's parable of
the talents
if you haven't read this it's really
dark real real
real dark not for your kids it's real
violence real dark
it is a masterpiece octavia butler is
extraordinary karen russell sleep
donation these are all fiction by the
way
this book was a trip um
i loved it in fact i'd recommend this
book to everybody that's a good book
again all these are really dark dark
fiction um
steven graham jones the only good
indians again this is a horror novel
it's scary pants
and real dark too but it was just a
masterpiece
and then i'm still working through nk
jemisin she is the
i think she's the best science fiction
writer in the world um how long do black
future month this is just a collection
of short stories
that man i wish my had this kind of
imagination so that's the fiction i've
read
in the last month or two i've been on a
fiction kick lately i kind of got burned
out on science so i'm just sticking to a
couple of nerd books over here but
man that's what i'm reading right now i
do again i read a lot i don't have a lot
of friends and so it kind of works out
that way
um what are my favorite fiction books of
all time i actually grabbed them off my
shelf and brought them what's your
favorite fiction book of all time kelly
uh to kill a walking bird oh you would
how noble and whatever of you it's one
that i read probably
once a year i just go back and read it
do you talk do you bring it up at
cocktail parties on
like you'd be like everybody what's your
favorite fiction book mine's to kill a
mockingbird
i mean i have others i mean and i read
some pretty like
low brow fiction sometimes but that's
just my favorite that i go back to
like once a year and just reread it just
for the enrichment of your soul
yeah just because i'm better than you
[Laughter]
james what about you um i like the
dystopian
future books like the brave new worlds
in the 1984
listen this is i'm gonna give you this
today butler this is the best dystopian
future novel i've ever read in my life
ever
love it ever let's do it all right good
and then we'll both read to kill a
mockingbird
just to cleanse our souls right so we
can reach kelly's higher plane there
um all right so my number one favorite
book of all time
is this danny the champion of the world
uh by raul dahl he's a guy that wrote
charlie the chocolate factory james the
giant peach
he's one of my favorite authors of all
time this is a book about a dad
and a son a little boy the little boy's
mom passes away and it's just them too
and they go get the man and it's one of
my favorite stories
it makes me cry a hundred percent of the
time i've read it so much throughout my
life it didn't even have a back cover
i've got two or three other copies but
this is my og
book um the catcher in the rye actually
carried this book around with me this is
the first time
i ever back in high school right um
chris lowe's the guy was a freshman he's
like hey you gotta read this book
and this is the first time i ever read a
book and thought oh gosh somebody's in
my head
um and then this book fight club this is
one of the origin this one book was
again one of those books that
in my early 20s i think when i found it
was like
whoa somebody's reading my mail and that
was a pretty remarkable book
and then the yearling and where the red
fern grows if you haven't read these two
books stop what you're doing cause i'm
about to ruin the image of style you're
used to you gotta read these books
they're so sad but they're so good
those are like the saddest books ever
written sadder than to kill a
mockingbird
yes oh my gosh yeah i'm the one without
a soul ladies and gentlemen
kelly and um huck finn is awesome
jaber crow by wendell berry is awesome
um the harry potter series is great
and to kill a mockingbird that's just
not it's not one of my favorites
it's a great book but it's not one of my
favorites um
yeah those are those books all right so
what our next question
what are the best books for raising
children
okay here's my little rant on this
right now for maybe the last 25 years i
think dobson did this right
he kind of started this in the jesus
circles and then there's been a couple
of other folks
in other circles this obsession with
strategies and scaling and projections
and norming we are so obsessed with
step-by-step plans for
our kids and there are some good plans
out there and some good questions but
i'm more interested in the foundation
stuff because what i found is if you
take care of the foundation stuff
the individual questions answer
themselves a lot
so i'm more interested in helping
parents be whole humans
and helping them deal with their own
crap and then being able to love their
kids and be
present with their kids and be able to
be mature adults who love and model
boundaries and good relationships
and then kids turn out fine right if a
parent is well their kids are going to
be able to handle the world as it comes
at them
right so when p parents ask me hey
what's the best parenting book i always
tell them
books for you and that is my go-to
is i don't want to talk about it by
tyria reel for men
um adult children of emotionally
immature parents we talked about that
earlier
by lindsay gibson um that's for
everybody
there's a it's a book it's a written by
a
pastor um i know a bajillion people who
listen this podcast aren't
don't have a faith affiliation but um
the book is
really remarkable with or without a
faith connotation and it's called the
ruthless elimination of hurry by john
mark comer
it's really really good um just as a
really good
introspective look at the way we're
living our lives and then there's a book
finding meaning by david kessler man i
probably
i think i've sold that guy a lot of
books it's just the the book on grief i
got up on my shelf up there
um so many parents don't have to grieve
and they don't have to deal with their
past they don't have to deal with
this fake picture they had of their
future and they just get stuck on these
loops then they end up just looping back
to their origin stories and they just
recreate it again and again and again
and that book just helps people walk
through
your life is not going to be the
fantasies you had the pictures you had
and you got to deal with them as they
come and
man that book's magic so if you will
love and connect with your kids
find and model joy give your kids
purpose right let them endure struggle
but also show up and give them
boundaries and show them that they
matter
they're resilient they're built like
gumby man they will come back
right and then if you need some very
specific books then you can deal with
those specific things at that time
that's what i tell people if they ask me
for books on raising kids is that kind
of a pass kind of but i want parents to
be
okay parents are not okay and they're
looking for strategies to help fix their
kids
all right so the next question um
ooh you wanna get a fight phone usage
for kids
i don't think we've ever talked about
this phone usage for kids
what is my rules for phone usage for
kids what's yours james
um my kid oh that was a good that was a
good
i i would have prepared for this if i'd
known you're going to toss us so many
questions
our kids don't use phones and they won't
for as long as
i can help it yeah but also i don't want
to i don't want to just jump in and
not have any experience and health you
know healthy boundaries with it so
um actually that's not true they use
phones for they shoot home movies all
the time with old
our old phones so but they're not like
on social media or on the internet or
anything
yeah uh we started we let our
our son have a phone when he started
coming home by himself
because we don't have a home phone but
we started with
um so 25 a month was worth the sole of
your child i could see that yeah you
know
but uh give and take give it we
started with just only an old phone with
no sim card
and then when he turned i think 15 we
let him but i am
all up in it i look through it all the
time
he knows that i'll come up and grab it
when he's talking you know looking
scrolling i'm and i mean my husband's
i.t so
he can't get away with much he can't get
away with anything yeah so my
rule of thumb get this
my son's in fifth grade he came home a
few weeks ago
a hundred percent of the kids in his
class
not only have smartphones they're ten
they all have these tick tock accounts
and they all are
hanging out back and forth and it he
discovered
live he's been left out of all this
stuff
it was hard but the hardest thing was
i thought i'd know what's going on this
is
madness that a 10 year old has that kind
of access
so in my house man like i'm i'm like
james
james and i are clearly better parents
than kelly but um no
yeah no kids aren't as old as kelly's
yet yeah
come on listeners don't be a teenager
now my son has no social media and he
will not for quite some time
that's not even enough man the data is
so clear if you have a 10 year old don't
let them have social media
there's a 15 year old don't let them no
no it's weird
in this era of digital babysitters
they're growing up being babysat by
other fifth graders
it it's just insane it's insane so
i i will hand them a phone if they are
facetiming like their grandparents
grandparents or an aunt or something
like that and we do have old phones like
you guys have
um where they download books in the
library like books they can listen to
audio books
but other than that they don't even ask
it's it's the
the data is so clear on how destructive
this is for kids
and now we're in a world where a 12 year
old says something texts something
and that's going to keep him from
getting a job when he's 40. and i want
my kids to be kids as long as they can
be
it's just gotten very unforgiving the
world overnight
and so it's just it's just not worth the
risk
um we have talked about kelly this is
awesome i was on a ladder
and it was just me and my son was at
home and i took a step in the ladder
i mean it was like i thought oh this is
it i'm coming down
and because i'm part ninja i stopped it
that's not at all it just stopped
miraculously and my son was looking at
me his eyes were really wide and he was
probably five or six and i said
if i had just fallen and gotten hurt
what would you have done
and he looked at me for a second and
sprinted to his room and got an old
trashed cracked like plastic flip phone
and he's like i would have called 9-1-1
and i was like man i'd be dead
right so we've talked about getting a
landline we just haven't done it but
we're going to do that soon
all right next question what was my
research for my phds
um i was a qualitative researcher i care
way more about individual stories than
going a mile deep than a quantitative
researcher
you can google the difference between
qualitative and quantitative there's all
kinds of
fist fights on the internets from
academics about which is better and why
and all that
my first dissertation i studied conduct
processes
at small private universities
small private colleges and ultimately
what i wanted to know is this
um who are you when somebody gets out of
step
with your values are you somebody who
one-and-dones people and kicks them out
are you somebody who helps you know the
buzz term now is restorative justice do
you help people
become whole with your community again
how do you deal with
your community when somebody steps out
of line with your values
i believe ultimately at the end of the
day who you say you are
is is um evident by how you treat people
who have violated your boundaries and
that's a hard thing for us as a country
we've got to deal with that's a hard
thing for us as parents we've got to
deal with
and so that's what i was looking at with
these colleges you can say we're pro
student and we love students and we are
all about student experience and blah
blah blah
but if you do this you're gone get out
right and for an 18 year old that's not
learning
a lot of the time and so i worked in
student conduct for years and years and
years and one of my
goals was how can is there a way we can
get the student back in here and learn
some of these lessons here
so that they can go out and be a great
citizen out there and i've benefited
from that my second one
my second dissertation i study
therapists who work with
lawyers and specifically i wanted to
know if lawyers
struggle with different mental health or
relationship challenges and other
clients and so
i spent a lot of time with therapists
who work with attorneys and so that's
what i studied there
and that was a fascinating conversation
about the mental health of people whose
job is to deal with other people in
their worst moments
it was uh eye opening a couple of years
i spent research in that stuff
all right so the next question is what
are my favorite podcasts
that i listen to i don't listen to a ton
the ones i do
the drive by peter atiyah if you're not
listening to that
get it it's hard it's it is real dense
sometimes
he is just a master teacher i don't know
what she taught in med school so i'm
glad he doesn't because
he he gets into this stuff he's he's
he's the master um the therapist shows i
love esther perells where should we
begin
i think is a masterpiece esther perel is
just a master clinician
she's as good as it gets and there's a
new show out called nurture versus
nurture with dr mogul
and it's man she's really really good
she's a psychologist as well
and um she does a deep dive both esther
perel and dr mogul do
deep dives one hour with a couple or one
hour with the family and it's
it's remarkable those are great podcasts
um occasionally armchair expert
um jack sheppard monica padman they
cracked me up and um they've got some
great guests on there
occasionally jocko's podcast when i just
need to stop and do a slim gym that's
good
and i love um kind of
obsessively uh the art form of stand-up
comedy and so
sometimes i'll just scroll through and
look for comedians and listen to their
live stuff or listen to how they write
and why they write and how their heads
work
i think that stand-up comedy is the last
great pure art form and i say that
because there's no layer
it's in real time here's what's going on
in the world
here's just a microphone and reflect go
and some folks like um
bergatzi and chappelle some of these
guys are some of these guys have
um are able are commenting in real time
now and their
ability to crank out sets and new
material and
put it out in the world it's really
remarkable so i love them
they're good and that's kind of it for
podcast you guys got any favorite
podcast you want to
give to the world you're all murder
podcast
not all i'm half murder half
like 15th century history oh my gosh so
it's depressing life
it well yeah it can be it's dark
so yeah there's a number of true crime
let's call it true crime that sounds
better than murder
it doesn't it does yeah so true crime
and then
usually british european or british 15th
century-ish
sorry it's not just british history it's
like
yeah very specific centuries of british
history it is there's a certain
time period is it from like outlander
did it start there what got you
interested in that um
probably actually started when my
parents took me to england when i was
like 10. oh gosh were you reading to
kill a mockingbird on the plane over
probably you would james do you have a
podcast that you love
not worth sharing they're all like nerdy
like
digital info security oh
that's why you're not giving it out i
see no it's just james has a mask on too
by the way
he actually has a mohawk he didn't even
look like that at all he's got a big
mustache
all right so what is my routine for
living with adult adhd
so here's a couple things that guide me
number one is this one sentence that
guides my life don't forget to remember
period
what does that mean that means i will
walk through
my life i i won't see a cop i'll i'll
i'll be
just rolling through the day but i
always remember how good it feels to get
into a clean car
i remember how good it feels to open my
door and there's laundry in there
and so i have to sometimes go back to my
truck one time two times make sure i've
got everything out of it
not because i really have this need to
make sure my truck is clean
but i remember how good it feels it's a
lot of it's about emotion
and if i can tie my current behavior to
a future
emotion that really works for me how do
i do that on a daily basis i write down
everything for almost every day of my
life
um i had some tough stuff happen with
recently and so i've been kind of
scattered all over the place i've been
writing stuff down
my morning routine shifted some um just
kind of been
and man it starts really kicking up i
forget things i'm kind of all over the
place
um james can and kelly are like hey hey
hey let's get going let's get going and
um the next thing that's important for
me is sleep sleep sleep sleep sleep
routine is important um
and part of that routine is man do the
same things every day as much as you can
do the gratitude do the workout do the
cold shower do the breakfast do the week
whatever that is it's all about routine
routine
and the second big thing is connection
for whatever reason grounds adhd in a
really remarkable way
which makes it hard right because you
are cycling out and you are annoying to
be around
which makes people not want to be around
you which makes your solution to that
problem being more annoying and more
faster and more going and going going
yeah so like i said i've been in a
lonely season
so it's been a hard february mess with
me a lot lots of stuff going on personal
life
live outside town so when i get lonely
my tics come back
might not like the bugs ticks but like i
believe i don't know i got a whole bunch
of stuff but my sleep gets messed up and
i stay up too late et cetera
so here's the deal living with somebody
requires people in your life that have
compassion and kindness
and mercy and grace i think a few months
in
when they realized you guys realized no
i'm not an idiot and i'm not
i'm kind of an idiot but i'm not lazy
i'm not trying to make your day bad
then a gentle reminder is really helpful
or james will
kelly print something out for me every
single day i don't hardly ever need it
but when i do i'm super glad she printed
it out right so it's just
living with folks and making sure
everybody around you works together
um yeah that's kind of it for me it's
connection and
routine and not forgetting to remember
how good this is gonna feel on the back
end of that
um oh here we go dude recorder post
listen to this nightmare so listen
listen i laugh
first at the things that i love and
things that make fun of me
i think things are hilarious especially
when they make fun of me
i don't live my life looking for a fence
right
the only offense i have really is when
people don't treat other people with
dating and respect it drives me crazy
and i can get pretty pissed off there
but more than more than like
if there is something making fun of
something that i love whether it's
religion
or my relationships or
um i don't know there's things i like
it makes me laugh it's funny
i am obsessed i think music education is
one of the most important things in the
world right my son's played the violin
for years we just got electric piano for
my little daughter
i've been playing guitar for 30 years
now um
my original um teachers miss mcadoo
right that was old school with the
xylophone the tata tt top i mean she
could rock it
um john marshall ron mccomis miss
hackett my choir teachers
dude my life's been about music ed and
my wife has been a teacher
and then she was a college professor who
taught teachers
i was a a high school teacher
i taught k-5 one year and i've been a
college professor for years
my whole family's about education my
whole family's about music and then
there's a natural intersection there
so the other day on the internets
somebody posted something along the
lines of
man as crappy as 2020 2021 has been
thank god for those recorder classes
when we were kids
i thought that was hilarious because i
remembered that ridiculous recorder
and i put it on this part of the
instagram thing that's with the stories
i was called
it's not the main thing but the
loop-de-loop thing i don't know there's
alt universe and this is the alt-alt
universe
and dude you would have thought i was
just putting up
pictures of dying pets i don't know
people got so mad who is so
angry at music educators why do you hate
music educators we're important people
i know you are i know listen
check this out
check this out i have a recorder
music educators miss mcadoo
i still remem check this out
how's that for baller hey check this out
i can trill it up
yeah look at that jethro toll how do you
like them apples
i love music ed i still love this
aqua blue recorder this is actually
ridiculous nobody should have this
but it's so good listen
for the sake of your soul please stop
looking through people's instagram posts
for reasons to get pissed off
if you look through somebody's thing and
it offends you
just just move on or
laugh if you're a music educator god
bless you
i don't know how you've taught recorder
through zoom
oh my gosh i'm so good at this i'm
amazing
uh kelly is literally she's got tears in
her eyes i can't tell if that is
is that joy no it's not is your heart
beating really fast
well but i've also gone through two kids
that have brought those home
so
[Music]
i could do this all day i'll stop please
oh man she's getting
you can feel it i can feel the i thought
it was a different kind of heat it's
anger heat it is i misread that my bad
um listen music educators you're good
people you're good
if you see a joke about recorders just
laugh just laugh your soul's gonna be
lighter
right it's gonna be lighter all right so
there's my
music ed i gotta just get off the
internets man people are
not being ugly they're just sad i know
it's hard all right so how often do i do
no
sugar months okay so
this is my confession
i kicked one off for the last ama we're
doing the no sugar
whatever new year failed i failed man i
crashed and burned then i felt guilty i
didn't want to tell
my 17 listeners that i had failed them
because i was getting instagram updates
from folks like
hey man it's really we're grinding it
out and i'm starving and i
hate my family but i'm doing it we're in
this together and like a coward i just
didn't say anything i didn't lie i kind
of lied by omission i didn't say
anything and man i felt so guilty
so listen i contacted my buddy john
who's
an active navy seal he's in the seals
and i said i'm going to text you every
day for 30 days
a counter app that i have i just took a
screenshot and i sent it to him
and if i don't i will had a pretty awful
awful consequence and i made it so i got
through february
with none in february sooked it was hard
um so here's the thing on a regular
basis i don't have a lot of sugar
um i almost have no grains we'll talk
about this later except for my wife's
sourdough bread and if she makes
homemade sourdough bread she like has a
pet sourdough starter
i can crush it um and then the other
night we had people
sleep over like they tinted out in our
in our field
at our house and they roasted
marshmallows i had a couple of jumbo
marshmallows i just don't have a lot of
sugar
unless i do and if i do
whoa whoa i can get pretty
pretty wild about it so i try just as a
rate on a regular basis just to not have
very
much um but then i do and then it leads
to the next i mean but then when i do
oh boy we get after it um detail about
the foods i eat
last night i had whatever dinner last
night i had
i'm by myself right now my family's out
of town i had two avocados
three eggs and some grass-fed beef liver
um we bought a bunch of cow organs from
a grass-fed butcher in missouri
and then i cooked it all in like
kerrygold butter that's what i had
i have a lot of high fat not i hardly
ever eat grains
um lots of high fat good healthy fats
and uh
good protein breakfast yesterday what i
have for breakfast today
i had yeah coffee with some of dr
the collagen powder from dr josh axe i
like his stuff
coffee with like a sheep liver or with a
pony
a pony's pancreas pancreas
what is that sounds a nice ring to it
hey if you want google eating uh um
organs oregon meats google it and
there's also some people on internet
that are
insane right like dude all you need to
do is just
can we just not be insane that's all
there is to it so here's the thing
uh it's old vinnie tortora it's right no
sugar no grain i had what two avocados
for lunch today i didn't eat any
breakfast
except for this little collagen powder
my rule of thumb is nsg no sugar no
grains most of the time
as much vegetables as you can put in
your body occasionally i'll have a
you know apple or part of a banana steal
for my daughter
i eat berries and cream a lot especially
in the evening time you can get buy
those bags of
frozen berries and i'll have cream with
those uh if my wife makes so many
cookies i'm gonna have 76 of them
and then i'm gonna um wish i was dead
the next day and it's worth it every
time
um the other night i had a buddy like we
talked about i had a buddy that passed
away
and somebody ordered a bunch of pizza
and i put myself into a near diabetic
coma it was awesome
like a uh good member of a faith
community i ate myself my ate my sorrows
that day
um here's that's just how it works for
me my wife actually eats different than
me
and it works for her so we've um
work with our particular doctors to to
do what works for us
um that's how i do it that's the
question um i don't know
how do you eat james you get kind of
similar to me huh
um ideally i do but it just depends on
how
much i stick to it but yeah try to eat
you know
sort of keto yeah that's a good way to
say it sort of keto-ish yeah i try to
fast a lot if i can't but
yeah i haven't been good lately yes i
don't want to talk about it
oh you should get that book well played
there you go kelly
my idea of a fast is between breakfast
and lunch
if i don't eat there i'm fasting well
and the big the big thing is if right
yeah um
my problem that i have is i like to bake
ah man my wife my son is a baker dude
which is how i knew that you fell off
the wagon in january
because i didn't know you had gone back
to sugar and i baked cookies one day and
you came in and grabbed like a handful
and i was like well i guess that's over
i was literally smearing them on my face
you rolled it on
somebody called hr on on me yeah they're
like hey he's grossing us out with the
cookies yeah i could
we try to eat a lot of um real food
that's our thing
at home we just try to eat real foods
yeah and
then you know stuff that doesn't come
out of a box or a bag or something
we have one night a week where we try to
support a local restaurant
yeah we take out do you all take your
copy of uh
to kill a mockingbird there i do the
entire family i read to them at dinner
wow it's great yeah that's i want to
change my answer we get pizza once a
week too and it's to support a local
restaurant
[Laughter]
well played we get super intoxicated we
support the local uber economy just
kidding way down but
i don't know what y'all do good gosh um
hey
so here's the thing if you want to
figure out what diet works for you
i always recommend to everybody go get
the whole 30 book and just start there
it's an elimination diet it's very clean
and it's easy
just do it for 30 days and your life
will suck
it is hard you got to get you do it with
somebody and you got to hold each other
accountable
ask james i almost killed him once on
whole30. but then you find out right
because then you start
he came in with a chick-fil-a biscuit
did you stab him for it well
we were in a meeting and she was like
you need to leave now james
because i was just it was like day eight
oh
dude yeah he walked in just eating a
chick-fil-a biscuit you're playing that
around your time off kelly he's still
here
yeah as you can see he's one less limb
but he's still gonna say he had both
both legs back then so about day eight
to thirteen
when you have cut grains and sugar out
your everything in your life is awful
and you will recognize oh maybe i'm an
addict and that's what happened to me
um anyway do hole 30 cut that stuff out
and then you slowly add it back in
most of us have never gone 30 days
without
bread or 30 days without rice or 30 days
without you know milk or something like
that and when you add it back in
man your body will be like nope we're
out right exit strategy and
we'll talk about that here in a little
bit uh what supplements do i take man
i hate to say this because people go out
and just buy all these
um here's what here's what i take
um so i'm kind of
annoying about my where i get my stuff
from
and what i take i get 99 of the
the supplements i take is from a company
called thorn
um i just trust them i've met with their
people they're really good they're
trustworthy and their stuff's real pure
it's not stuff you get like at walgreens
or whatnot
um i do take creatine on a regular basis
it's got so much it's one of the most
researched supplements in the world
i do take full spectrum hemp oil several
times a week
um occasional melatonin thorn's
multivitamin i've taken that for years i
cycle on and off that
um throughout this year as the research
emerged with coveted stuff i
did take a lot of vitamin d
vitamin dk again i don't know ultimately
how it's going to play out i don't know
if that's causal or if it is more
correlational but
again it's like 20 bucks and
if there's this chance it's going to
help me out then let's let's do that
i do take a lot of vitamin c a lot of
zinc
farm gaba uh have you tried that james
um i got i've started some yeah recently
yeah yeah oh man i
i love it it helps me sleep it's pretty
good some people has
no effect on um fish oil is a huge deal
whether it's dha dhea fish oil is
important
and then i recently read some stuff on
the blood sugar support from moringa
powder so i'm trying that out i put
way too much in my coffee this morning
and it tastes like somebody had died
about a week ago and i was trying to
drink it it was awful
and so i poured about 111 cup of coffee
down the
after all the stuff i had put in it um
but i couldn't handle it but
try moringa powder so i rotate stuff out
i try stuff um i've got several other
things i've taken now just to see what
happens
that's what i take on a quasi-regular
basis it is expensive
it is and if i could only take one thing
on that list it would probably be that
multivitamin and
it's really good thorns multifarm is
really good and um
that creatine is really good too um all
right
sweetest thing i've ever done for my
wife that surprised her
i just tried to think of a few things a
surprise for the trip to malibu once
um we were just newlyweds we went for
like two nights
um one time i stuck uh concert tickets
to a dave matthews show we were living
in one city
i know i know that was a surprise or
like a punishment
she really she burned the roast and so i
was like that's it we're flying another
city to go see dave matthews
um but i put it in like a magazine and
she opened it and read it and it's like
what are these
and we went and got on airplane it was
kind of fun we went to some friends here
is probably
the coolest thing so we were uh i don't
know if we were dating or married at the
time
i think we had just i don't know she's
all about country music i don't know a
lot about country music
and george strait was a big dude i heard
the name but i didn't know about him
and they were closing down the astrodome
where i spent a lot of time as a kid
going to astros games used to be able to
go for four bucks to see the astros game
so in high school we win a lot
and so i called a guy who knew a guy
um rick noodleman was his name came up
with two tickets for that show
it was like a it was like a military
processional
the president was there george strait
comes in on a horse
there's like a million people in the
astrodome
people are weeping cr i looked at my
wife right when george strait came out
she just starts
i was like what is happening here and it
was like a church service
it was a church service with them eight
million people in the astronaut
i think that was probably the smoothest
thing probably the worst surprise
that was the least sweet so here's my
proposal story
i got all my buddies together we've been
dating for five years off and on and we
break up
get back together thought i was gonna
marry somebody else that didn't work out
anyway this is the day i'm going to do
it on my birthday so you'll never see it
coming
and at this restaurant it's papacito's
man in houston it's the greatest mexican
food in the world
and um that's probably a little bit of a
generalization i like the restaurant how
about that
and we were um i was going to propose
there and when you told them it's your
birthday
they would silence the whole restaurant
have you stand up on a chair and then
they all say happy birthday to you
so great i got all my buddies in on this
i handed one guy the rings i wouldn't
chicken out
we go there and it is packed super
hopping
it is chaos and then you know they my
buddies did the right thing and they
told the you know the waitress like hey
it's this guy's birthday like okay we'll
take care of him
so we finished dinner nothing and we're
all just kind of sitting there
like nothing nothing
then my buddies think it's hilarious and
they start passing the ring down the
table
and they're hiding it behind drinks or
behind chips and i'm getting more
nervous what are we doing here
and then this poor waiter comes out and
he is sweating
he's so busy it's so hot and it's
houston
it everyone's running around and he just
shows up
with a 18-foot sombrero
a giant hat and a piece of cake and he's
like
hey is this on his birthday and i was
like yeah it's me and he
tosses the cake on the table and he puts
his hat on me and he goes
happy birthday man and he just runs off
and by this
time they'd move the ring to where it's
like my drink and it's right behind it
and then there's
my like my girlfriend and i froze and i
didn't know what to do
i should have bailed i should have just
been like not tonight guys
and i didn't and i just like awkwardly
was like
and i just got down on a knee in the
middle of a bustling restaurant with a
huge sombrero on
and i was like hey to which my wife was
like are you serious
and the whole i was like yes this is it
and it just was brown so i thought it
was going to be all sweet and romantic
it was terrible
that's the sweetest thing that i thought
i did that was not a good surprise
it surprised there wasn't a great
surprise how about that
okay so how many listeners do i actually
have james
so one of the running jokes on the show
is we have like 17 listeners i think
we're up to 25
probably by now i did go check the
youtube
show had a million plus views in
february so it's
here's the thing i have the same five
friends i've had since grade school
i've made like a few friends along the
way but like i just am not that cool
and so when i see numbers like a million
views and like that
makes my head explode it's like a
cartoon so we had over a million views
in february
um that's a lot tens and
tens of thousands of regular podcast
listeners so the whole thing's gotten
really big underneath this that's why
they made me move out of the
our safe studio into this big flashy
shiny thing
um and then if you throw in dave's
co-host dave ramsey show a couple times
a week and so that's millions of
millions so it's a whole thing
if you're listening to this you're part
of a cool gang you're in it on the
inside though
and so for my head literally
psychologically i've just got to assume
it's just me
and my mom and a few friends and some
cool people who hang out with us
in the lobby partying y'all making my
day better i'm glad y'all are here it's
good to see you for those who are
listening there's
a whole audience full of people in my
audience i mean three
and it's good to see you guys y'all make
my heart feel good
um so that's how many listeners we have
a lot
a lot but hey seriously send this
podcast to your friends
send it to them and either you can make
fun of it and be like look at this clown
or if you get something out of it send
it to your buddies and
hopefully i can get some out of it too
what would i say
to my younger self kelly what would you
say to the younger john
oh wow i wasn't prepared for this one
i know
hurry up
[Laughter]
is that a late joke my might be
i would try to develop those habits to
the younger john
so that the john that i deal with now
will you
be on time james what would you tell the
younger john
i would say hey humbuckers are overrated
get yourself a fender stratocaster
you're such a
human and defender princeton and a
couple good pedals and you'll be set
real man real men don't need les pauls
that's what i would tell them
real mean men need jingles
gosh fender people to be fair i would
probably say get your acid wash jeans on
we're going to see motley group
because and the younger john
we would hung out had a lot in common we
would have hung out yeah
there was a lot of hairspray involved i
used a lot of hairspray too
oh 80s texas did you have the poof
yeah gargantuan
yeah that's the whole thing i did have
some dope bastard wash jeans that i got
second hand i think from a dude named
brian bell he hooked me up with jeans
all the time
they were pretty rad um here's what i
would tell younger self
never steal delony don't steal
don't lie i was a little lying thief as
a kid i hate that
that's like one of the most shameful
parts of my childhood i hate that
um i would tell 18 year old 19 20 year
old 14 year old john
dude you got value and that's enough
it's enough
the defense mechanisms i built up over
the years man just because i was always
so insecure man
um i i just hate that because there's a
wake of people that you hurt along those
journeys right
um i would tell the younger me dude
treat people right all of the time
don't wait until later to learn that
lesson in fact i remember the person
and um
that i remember thinking i have to be
different after this and i wasn't
like i didn't do anything evil but man
i wish i could uh go back and treat a
few people better so i would treat
people right all the time
um i tell younger john stop worrying
about everything say yes more don't be
such a buzz kill i was a loser dude i
was such a nerd my buddies were like hey
let's go do something
fill in the blank and i was like well i
don't know guys we're probably gonna get
in trouble just shut up and go have fun
right go have fun the things i did i
actually went and didn't had fun
those are the memories we talk about not
like hey drone remember we all were in
bed by 9 30.
that's so stupid um yeah and i would
have gotten more sleep too
i did i was so so lame those things seem
a little better i do
here's the thing i wouldn't go out and
then i would sit up and watch usa up all
night movies
like a dork and so maybe we wouldn't
have been friends we would not have been
friends
no i'm all talk i was lame and then i
would have told this
to my younger self secrets will kill you
don't work somewhere you can't be full
of yourself where you can't be fully
open and don't work somewhere people
don't challenge you right
um that'd be big ones for me
like dude just get over yourself and
enjoy your life and
enjoyment means get some sleep and
enjoyment means
go to jail once or twice sometimes it's
funny right
all right so what's my most embarrassing
moment
how much of these can we say well let's
not get canceled
yeah i think you've already uh you've
already pushed it today
no i haven't all right i'll give you
probably okay in order the most
embarrassing moments number one
i um
i still think david did it but i dropped
the baton in first place
in the mile relay my senior year and
i we lost the meet by one point and it
was the first meet that team had lost in
10 years that was going to be the
10-year win there was olympians on that
team it was kind of a nationally ranked
track team to this day i'll get a text
like once every two or three years from
the
the guy who's running third leg who
handed me the baton he'll just be like
you dropped it
and i'll be like nope you did like it
still haunts me
um that was an embarrassing moment that
just broke my heart a few years ago at
the law school
um i guess we'll just edit this out if
we can't use this
i was i mean i was at the law school and
i was just going to bathroom
and in my suit
and as i would tell my children
i thought i was gonna toot
and james
i got more than i bargained for and i
hear the thing i'm
at work at a law school in a suit and i
had to like
waddle sprint out of the building and
get to the parking lot i went all the
way i just went home
i just can't source it they went home
that was pretty embarrassing i had to
cancel meetings
and i used to lie to your co-workers you
can't tell the truth like why why are we
canceling
secrets kill relationships that's why
i'm i'm being honest that was something
should be kept secret no that was
embarrassing it happened
i crapped my pants at work everybody
that's what happened that's what
happened
um yeah those are a couple of good ones
oh dude i just have a lifetime of
embarrassing moments
i just think like the other day i was i
i just am awkward man and i don't know
what to say i don't know how to just say
like hi how are you
and i try to like start a thing and then
everyone's like this is weird
what are you doing and i don't know i
get embarrassed a lot i don't get
embarrassed anymore i embarrass the
people around me because i'm awkward
um advice for a therapist starting a
practice what would i tell them
here's what i tell you work really
really hard
and be really good and you get good both
inside and outside the therapy room
so what i mean by that um
learn to love people
if you don't love people don't be a
therapist love
people love their kids love their
stories love hearing about their weird
dogs
just love being with people it drives my
wife
crazy because i like to just sit there
and talk to the registered dude at
burger king we don't even break but
i just like talking to people and she's
like we seriously have to go
um and i just like talking to people and
the the therapist
the folks i know who are great
therapists it's hard for them to get
through a room
because they just love talking to people
they love interacting with other humans
and so
learn to love people um learn to sit
with people in their pain
that's hard and it's challenging and
it's spiritual
it's you can only learn it by practice
um
my first job coaching high school i
asked the head coach
when y'all are cutting players can i
just be in the room i want to watch how
y'all cut players
later on when i was in leadership when
someone's going to fire somebody i would
say hey can i be in that room i want to
see how this happens
how do you how do you gracefully
terminate somebody's employment how do
you take their
job away and let them keep their dignity
how do you sit with somebody when you've
just told them
you got to go home and tell your kids
and your wife you got fired
how do you sit in those moments and then
later on
how do you knock on somebody's door with
a police officer and say
i regret to inform you that your husband
was killed in a car wreck
how do you sit with somebody at home
when they know they've just lost a child
and they're racing to get home and
they're going to meet you
first you got to learn how to sit in
those moments and
the phrase i learned at the law school
that i love there's just power in the
pause just be quiet
and we are so conditioned to fill up
that space with
ticks and weird things and sayings and
that's when you say
stupid stupid stuff that ends up hurting
people and so if you want to be a really
good therapist starting to practice
learn to sit with people in their pain
sometimes you'll you'll be in
like session three or session four and
somebody will just say it they'll
finally say
i was abused or i've got to get out of
this marriage or i don't like my kids
they'll have something that's been
sitting in their soul and they'll
finally say it
and man if you're a therapist that tries
to like take that pain away and man you
just you
rob them of that healing process and so
you gotta learn to
sit in that in that pain with other
people and the last thing is
have a hardcore to the death will not
budge on it wellness plan for you being
a good therapist means you got to get up
and keep going you got to keep going and
you can only do that if you're well
otherwise you're going to get burnt out
you're going to melt your friends and
your family and your kids you're going
to bring that crap home with you
have a way that you can hose your boots
off at the end of every day when you get
done dealing with other people's crap
all day
that's what i'd recommend and work
really hard show up
be available in the middle of the night
be available in the first days as you're
building your practice you're going to
learn what you're good at you're going
to learn new skills
all right um oh kelly i think you sent
this in kelly
when did i get obsessed with diarrhea
references
i didn't but that person wanted me to
buy my new best friend
that was my new best friend all right so
here's when i got dire
i i've been i don't see obsessed i
thought diarrhea humor has been funny
forever i don't know why i think it's
hilarious
i think diarrhea is nature's eject
button it is like nature's like
everybody out i just think that on its
face is funny
um now if you are if you got dysentery
if you're gonna die i mean obviously
it's not funny but
i remember getting being so sick if
if this kind of story barfing and
diarrhea makes you sick just hit the
little
fast forward button a few times here but
i remember
being so sick yeah kelly's just plucking
plug your ears
but i always had a like you know it's
coming out
everywhere and i had a a trash can i'm
throwing
up into um it is
roller coaster out the you know out the
the the other exit and
i remember just dying laughing it was
the most uncomfortable but i remember
laughing
with like i was thinking what needs
out of my body this bad and it was
cracking me up because my body was just
like
everybody out everybody out and i just
remember thinking that's the funniest
thing
it's uncomfortable it's miserable it's
unpleasant and
then you know my family's humor my dad
was a homicide detective
he his humor just slanted a little bit
off my sister is the funniest person
i've ever met
she hurt she is ten times smarter than
me ten times
funnier me she's so fast and
um my friends beautiful butthead came
out when i was a kid and so that was
i mean that's just kind of what we grew
up on
honestly i don't know why here's the
honest truth america
and by america i mean 13 of you if i
have a diarrhea reference on this show
99 of the time i'm trying not to say a
bad word i'm trying to swear
i want this to be a show that people can
listen to in their car or their families
um and
i want my kids to be able to hear it and
so i try not to swear
and so when i'm like get really fired up
and i'm like that
box of farts on a stick and a bag of
diarrhea that is just me
not trying i'm just trying not to string
together a bunch of expletives because
i'm just trying to keep a nice show
as a producer i want to caveat that kids
should probably almost never listen to
the show
you've you've heard our subject matters
right i mean no child
i'm pretty sure this isn't a family
get-together [ __ ] i well maybe in
y'all's family
you're too busy serving the least of
these and kelly and kelly's household
and
james is too busy churning their own
butter out in their in their
chicken pasture which is dumb because we
have chickens that are i don't know why
i made fun of you about the way i live
my life too james i'm sorry
actually i just had to call to my
chickens yesterday so that's you just
triggered me did y'all eat them
no they were old and sickly and not
laying anymore so
had to go i see once just there you go
listeners when i stopped producing james
is going to recommend that dillon be
cold
and you call me dark and stuff hey it's
just the way the world
oh man wow it's very darwinian of you
james i'm glad to know
i don't know i think diary is funny
sorry
people people will send me cards and
letters letting me know that
they think it's gross it makes me sound
stupid
they're not listening anymore i get that
that's fine
whatever i think it's funny i envy their
choice
[Laughter]
i have hey we've dialed it way back
right
we i have dialed it way back
i'll give you that okay thank you not
way i'll give you you dialed it back
it's so hard there's so many funny jokes
i don't use all right
best woo-woo guidance i've ever received
so
in the biohacker world woo-woo is
is just a phrase for there is no
evidence to support that that does
anything
and now a bunch of weirdos are doing it
right
so i like trying every woo thing that
comes along
the way i think it's super fun and now
we're getting some good data because
you've got these fmri machines they've
got all kinds of wearables now that you
can actually track blood sugar and heart
rate and
sleep cycle you've got all this wearable
stuff that man we're getting
down the road on proving some of these
woo things
but the things that have made the most
impact in my life that i don't have any
dad never read data on
barefoot and grounding is a big deal for
me making sure i'm connected to the
ground so i
this morning when we went and let the
chickens out and ran the dogs around i
walked across our property with bare
feet and it was cold and it was
early and it was uncomfortable and
that's just a big deal for me i do that
every single day
i have read some data on cold cold
plunges cold showers i think that's good
but
um it's not probably the firmest science
um i think wimhoff has some science i
haven't
read all of it but cold showers is a big
deal for me both
neurologically psychologically
emotionally and just physiologically
it's good
um and then this is probably the most
one
i learned from the therapist here in
town and man whenever i am
angry with somebody or i'm frustrated or
i'm not connecting with somebody
oh it sounds so cheesy to just say it
out loud but it's called a heart breath
where you imagine like a
kind of a almost like care bears
remember when they used to like
shoot the things out of their chest like
out of their hearts
and like and connect with somebody
else's heart
i know that sounds so ridiculous i think
every single listener is like all right
we're done and sorry it's got
our podcast cancelled it's just my mom
hanging in there now
she's like oh my john and his heart
breath
but there's something when i get
disconnected with folks if i can just
imagine i'm tethered to them
it helps me plug in and look them in the
eye and make sure i am connecting a lot
of times when i'm
not hearing somebody right or someone's
annoying me they're driving me crazy
it's
on me it's because i'm not paying
attention and that helps me plug in with
somebody
there is no data that says our hearts
are connected sounds like a bon jovi
song but there you go
all right the last one here is what are
some favorite local nashville places
dude the ryman auditorium man it's one
of my favorite places in this community
i've seen some rad shows over there
um since we lived here back when you
could go to shows that was cool
frothy monkey is this dope little coffee
shop that's where i wrote most of my
dissertation i love it
um
bradner lake i love it's like a pristine
nature preserve here you can walk around
and just
look at other people and you all nod and
i don't know i like it
my kids run around there um i don't know
what do y'all think
do you have cool places that you love i
like ethan roast for coffee
eighth and roast eighth and roast
like a meat place but that's cool and
what about you
um my favorite place like like local
place would be bishops
oh i don't know what that is it's a it's
a meet in three
and it's where hattie b's chicken
started oh my god
so i had some last week some good
nashville hot chicken
if you come to nashville and want a
little bit of the aforementioned
diarrhea
hattie bees for sure i don't never get
diarrhea there i love that place
it's so good so so good good call on
that one i love how to be i love it
man there's so many local joints in
nashville it's like it's got the best
food
17.99 there's a lot of cool little cork
and cat all those places are just
rad man the red pony did it burn down
yeah it did
i don't know if they're gonna be able to
rebuild or what but it burned
well that's my favorite places um hey
that's the last that's the end of those
questions
so thank you so much um send all your
mean cards and letters
and i'm trying to cut back on the
diarrhea jokes james stay in school
don't do drugs
zach bennett hey you don't get enough
credit can we can't
you can't put a camera on you can you
come over here zach
just wave look he's wearing his green
hat st patrick's day today
james said i have to say hello into the
microphone so everyone can hear me that
is the most i've heard him talk since
i've met him a year he's got an amazing
radio voice
he does man it's awesome one of these
days we're gonna have him fill in for
you when you're gone
that would be the ratings will spike man
be like oh who's this this is awesome
but that's it that's that's the life
we're gonna come back in a few weeks
with
a sh what do we call it rapid fire rapid
fire
yeah relatively rapid yeah i was gonna
take about 15 minutes to explain what
rapid fire was which
again tells you the whole problem but
all right that's it um hey
today's lyrics let's end with a good one
man we went back old school to 1990
it's off the people's instinctive
travels and the paths of
rhythm a driver called quest dropped
grenades on that record this is this is
one it's on the radio
get over it purists i'm not doing deep
cuts today we're just introducing people
to the tribe
but it's called can i kick it and it
goes like this
can i kick it well i'm gone can i kick
it to all the people who can quest like
a tribe does see what they did there
before this did you really know what
live was comprehend to the track for its
why cause
getting measures on the tip of the
vipers rock and roll
oh on the tip of the viper sorry rock
and roll to the beat of the funk jazz
wipe your feet really good on the rhythm
rug
and if you can feel the urge to freak
you the jitterbug
come and spread your arms if you really
need a hug that's what this show is
about
i'm just ripping off a tribe called
quest come and spread your arms if you
really need a hug right here
on the dr john deloney show